a century ago a family of Italian
brothers set out to build cars or both
beautiful and fast cars designed for
motor racing as well as the road a
hundred years later Maseratis plans are
even more ambitious they're aiming to
lift sales nearly fivefold by 2018 a
tough task but they're on track to do so
maserati doubled sales last year and is
set to do the same again good news for
their owners the fiat group who need to
counter poor sales figures out of Europe
Maseratis eyeing the growing Asian and
US markets introducing six new models
including this one the alfieri named
after one of the founding brothers the
United States is still our biggest
market and I expect the United States to
account at the end of the year for a
third of our global sales china and the
asia-pacific region is the second
strongest center of gravity for our
business if I look back a couple of
years we saw eight hundred cars in these
markets in a year right now we are
selling this amount of cars in amongst
winning American and Asian hearts won't
be easy or cheap this year the company
paid top dollar for an advert during the
Super Bowl but Maserati CEO is confident
we are competing with outstanding
products and the Italian asst is an
important value of our products in the
global luxury markets with fee its
acquisition of us carmaker Chrysler
complete the Italians see this as a
perfect opportunity seduce new markets
Angus Bennett Bloomberg